[Music]
the brain is a magical organ for us to
hear sound it does things complex and
incredible but not unknowable the brain
takes sound waves which journey through
the air and through our skulls and
transforms them into sound in our minds
this sonic Odyssey is beautiful filled
with weird landscapes unexpected
encounters catastrophe and joyful
destinations all like a strange aural
fairytale hearing evolved because it
helped animals to survive hearing
allowed predators to find prey and eat
them and hearing allowed prey to spy on
predators in to escape the floppy piece
of skin attached to the size of our head
is our outer ear or Pina it collects
sounds from a wide area of our
environment like a reflector disk of a
satellite dish in humans the pinna is in
a fixed position but in many animals the
pinna are highly flexible and can be
oriented toward a source of sound
[Music]
curiously our auditory system has
evolved beyond its strict utility of
survival for example music through its
perception as sound by our auditory
system evokes sensations and emotions
sound is produced when something
vibrates causing variations in air
pressure particles of air collide with
other particles and the wave of movement
bouncing from particle to particle
passes outward through the air this is
called a sound wave and now our brave
sound waves are approaching the outer
ear and are truly starting their journey
once they've entered the ear through the
pinna they passed down the air-filled
auditory canal before hitting the
eardrum as the sound waves strike the
eardrum the vibrations in the air are
transferred through that membrane into a
series of little bones called the
ossicles there are three bones in this
group the malleus incus and stapes also
known as the hammer anvil and stirrup
they function to transmit sounds from
the air-filled outer ear into the
fluid-filled inner ear by allowing the
sound to enter them through the eardrum
vibrates rhythm and then exit into the
inner ear via a second membrane called
the oval window the inner ear contains
the sensory organs for both hearing as
well as for our sense of balance the
cochlea an important organ for the
auditory process is snail shaped and if
rolled up is only about the size of a
pea
inside the cochlea is the organ of Corti
which sits on the basilar membrane and
below the tectorial membrane and inside
the organ of Corti are thousands of
auditory hair cells these hair cells are
in fact receptor neurons called
stereocilia these hair cells convert the
motion energy of sound waves into
electrical signals that are communicated
to the auditory nerve from there the
signal goes into structures deeper in
the brain until at last it reaches the
auditory cortex where we consciously
experience sound to back up when our
sound waves enter the fluid-filled inner
ear they are thrust into a storm a storm
of vibrations that they are in fact
creating the basilar membrane below them
is violently shaking and tossing them
the tectorial membrane above them is
moving back and forth pushing and
threatening
and in the midst of this maelstrom as
they are broken apart they spiral
through the inner ear and the sound
waves finally begin to weaken the inner
ear absorbs all their kinetic strength
and the sound waves begin to realize
that this will be their end now
finally in the chaos of the inner ear
they disappear
the sound waves have ceased to be but
though the vibrations are now no more
they are not completely gone
they have metamorphosed into something
new into neural activity and they come
to life again in the cortex of the brain
in the consciousness of our mugs their
journey is over the brain is taken what
was outside and made it inside
[Music]